Narrator: WHAT DO YOU DO
WHEN YOU'RE UNDERWATER
AND YOU WANT TO FRESHEN UP
YOUR MOUTH?
THERE'S SOMETHING FISHY
GOING ON.
HOW CAN HE LET THOSE FISH
INSIDE HIS MOUTH?
Narrator: THIS IS DIVE MASTER
MICHAEL MILNER
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE RED SEA
IN EGYPT.
SO, HOW DOES MICHAEL TURN FISH
INTO FLOSS?
THESE FISH ARE
BLUESTREAK CLEANER WRASSE,
AND THEY OPERATE THINGS
CALLED CLEANING STATIONS
ON CORAL-REEF ENVIRONMENTS.
THEY'LL ACTUALLY EAT
THE DEAD SCALES AND SKIN
AND MUCUS AND PARASITES
OFF OF OTHER ANIMALS.
THEY'RE CALLED
"OBLIGATE CLEANERS."
IT'S JUST WHAT THEY DO.
IT'S HOW THEY GET
THEIR FOOD.
IT'S ACTUALLY
THEIR ENTIRE SOURCE OF FOOD.
Krishna-Pillay: THEY'RE NOT AT
ALL FUSSY ABOUT WHAT THEY EAT,
AND THEY CAN CONSUME UP TO
1,200 PARASITES A DAY.
NOW, THIS IS A MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL THING FOR THEM TO DO.
ANOTHER FISH
GETS TO BE FREE OF PARASITES,
AND THEY GET TO EAT
SOME PARASITES.
Narrator: BUT MICHAEL'S
NOT A FISH,
SO WHY ARE THESE WRASSE
DOING MOUTH MAINTENANCE?
MICHAEL MAY HAVE ATTRACTED THE
SERVICES OF THESE CLEANER FISH
BECAUSE HE HAD
RECENTLY EATEN A MEAL
AND, CLEARLY,
HE DIDN'T BRUSH OR FLOSS,
BECAUSE THE FISH WERE ATTRACTED
TO THE SMELLS
COMING FROM HIS MOUTH.
Narrator:
AND THAT'S HOW YOU CLEAN YOUR
"TEEF" WHEN YOU'RE ON A REEF.